après jean yves le drian en 2016 cette
fois c'est florence parly qui est venu
garantir l'avenir du site de garchizy et
le maire de la commune est le premier à
s'en réjouir
avec la restructuration de l'armée ce
site aurait pu disparaître comme
beaucoup d'autres et il ya eu ce passage
à l'industriel privé renault trucks
defense qui est devenu aujourd'hui arcus
qui maintient d'abord un qui maintient
le savoir-faire du territoire et les
compétences industrielles sur du
matériel militaire et donc c'est une si
oui on va dire c'est une très belle
affaire entre guillemets quand je dis
affaire on n'est pas là pour faire des
affaires mais quand même pour le
territoire
dans ses ateliers arcus assurait déjà
l'entretien et la réparation des blindés
légers mais l'industriel va développer
une nouvelle activité toute la
logistique des pièces détachées pour les
véhicules de l'armée de terre sera gérée
ici c'est donc un site fourchambault qui
est essentiel pour le bon fonctionnement
des armées française et pour assurer la
continuité des opérations que nous
menons aussi bien sur des théâtres
d'opérations extérieures que pour les
autres les missions d'entraînement et de
préparation opérationnelle que nous
conduisons ici sur le territoire
national la plateforme logistique
aménagé sur le site nivernais est tout
juste opérationnel 10 millions d'euros
d'investissement 18 mille mètres carrés
et côté gros chiffres ça n'est pas
terminé
on va également gérer d'ici la fin 2020
gérer plus de 30 mille pièces de
rechange
c'est pour nous effectivement une très
grande opportunité et par ailleurs il
faut savoir qu effectivement aujourd'hui
cette partie plate forme logistique
représente quasiment un tiers des
effectifs de sites de fourchambault et
ça ne va que croître quatre sont
salariés travaillent déjà aujourd'hui
pour arcus ici en 2006 ils n'étaient
qu'une petite dizaine